la inversión y la intensa relación
comercial que tenemos En definitiva creo
que desde el punto de vista bilateral
estamos reforzando nuestras relaciones
en el encuentro empresarial de esta
mañana pues se han avanzado En esa
dirección dando continuidad al al Foro
económico que se organizó en Bogotá con
ocasión de mi visita a Colombia en el
pasado mes de agosto y hoy hemos hablado
de proyectos concretos en sectores muy
importantes de alta incidencia para la
sociedad colombiana y también española
como es el aeronáutico la conectividad
los ferrocarriles los satélites la
digitalización de la sanidad en las en
la que empresas españolas van a poner
tecnología y know how al Servicio del
desarrollo y la cohesión social y
territorial en Colombia hemos firmado
algo muy importante es un protocolo
financiero entre los ministerios
ministerios de comercio en nuestro caso
de industria y turismo perdón de ambos
países y les anunció que España va a
poner a disposición mil millones de
euros
a través de diferentes instrumentos de
cooperación en el comercio en la
inversión para la financiación de
proyectos en sectores prioritarios con
empresas españolas En tercer lugar hemos
hablado de esta importante cumbre de la
Unión Europea y la celac que va a tener
lugar en Bruselas el próximo mes de
julio Creo que ambos ejecutivos
compartimos la importancia de que la
región latinoamericana tenga una voz
internacional propia
la relevancia de contar con un refuerzo
en la relación política económica social
cultural de Colombia con la Unión
Europea y también lógicamente de la
comunidad latinoamericana y de ahí la
importancia que le damos desde el
gobierno de España lógicamente a esa
cumbre de la Unión Europea con la cela
que no se celebra desde el año 2015 y yo
creo que esto también siempre hay que
recordarlo por las oportunidades
perdidas que yo Ha representado pero
también por la voluntad política que
estamos demostrando de reforzar y
relanzar estas estas relaciones también
Pues como no puede ser de otra manera la
necesidad de superar el bloqueo político
en Venezuela que se prolonga ya durante
demasiado tiempo España como saben los
medios de comunicación tanto de Colombia
como de España participó en la
conferencia ministerial que el
presidente Petro organizó la semana
pasada en Bogotá con objeto de relanzar
el diálogo entre Nicolás maduro y la
oposición algo que consideramos que es
vital para encontrar una solución a la
crisis que ya dura demasiado tiempo en
Venezuela y que sea una solución que
llegue cuanto antes ambos queremos
participar en la búsqueda de salidas
para la aguda crisis migratoria que
sufre la región con un impacto muy
directo en Colombia y quiero subrayar el
papel de Colombia en la acogida de
refugiados y de refugiadas es un ejemplo
creo querido presidente de solidaridad
que ennoblece al pueblo colombiano y que
España valora desde la más absoluta
empatía es necesario abordar las causas
de esta crisis desde su raíz el
planteamiento que siempre ha tenido
España cuando hemos tenido que afrontar
no crisis de refugiados sino en este
caso las crisis migratorias que también
ha sufrido España y en paralelo debemos
encontrar soluciones urgentes como la
creación de vías de migración legales
ordenadas seguras una materia en la que
España creo es un referente a seguir a
nivel europeo y en ese contexto pues
ambos países hemos renovado un acuerdo
de migración circular muy importante
cuya primera fase concluyó con éxito y
que nos va a llevar a doblar el número
de beneficiarios y beneficiarias yo creo
que esto es muy relevante y del mismo
modo estamos tratando de Buscar
soluciones para este drama humanitario
que tiene lugar en la región de del
Darién entre Panamá y Colombia una de
las rutas migratorias más complejas
también las más peligrosas del mundo en
la que la acción internacional
coordinada con los países afectados
resulta esencial
en cuarto lugar y por último hemos
acordado trabajar ante la emergencia de
los grandes desafíos con carácter global
desafíos ante los que compartimos creo
una misma visión y a los que debemos
responder siendo conscientes de su
trascendencia y de surgencia no solo
para nuestras respectivas ciudadanías
sino por su impacto mundial y sus
efectos en las futuras generaciones y en
esos términos creo que la lucha contra
la emergencia climática es una prioridad
para ambos gobiernos y por eso Quiero
agradecer se lo he dicho personalmente
al presidente Petro que que haya
anunciado la intención de Colombia de
unirse a la alianza internacional para
la resiliencia ante la sequía que
lanzamos conjuntamente España con
senegal en la cop 27 en San bersey se
trata de una iniciativa de la que ya
forman parte 31 países cuyo objetivo es
compartir buenas prácticas desarrollar
proyectos relacionados con la
desertificación y la gestión del agua
saben ustedes que España
desgraciadamente lleva ya muchos meses
sufriendo un problema de sequía muy
grave España lógicamente por ubicación
geográfica es un país enormemente
expuesto según nos dice la ciencia a las
consecuencias de esta emergencia
climática el impacto de esta amenaza
real es devastador no solo para nuestra
agricultura que es una industria muy
potente en nuestro país sino para la
supervivencia de tesoros naturales la
biodiversidad de nuestro país que
también es extraordinariamente rica y en
ese sentido Yo quiero también señalar
que Colombia es un referente Global en
biodiversidad es un país crucial para
librar una batalla en la que debemos
unir fuerzas al Amparo de la ciencia que
que lleva décadas advirtiendo sobre la
emergencia climática Y en este sentido
ambos países compartimos también el
interés por impulsar la necesaria
transición energética para que sea las
energías verdes las que muevan a
nuestras industrias y también
nuestras sociedades En definitiva no me
quiero extender más compartimos querido
presidente creo que una visión
esperanzadora sobre las enormes
oportunidades de la transición ecológica
y también de la transformación digital
en nuestras sociedades pero debemos
hacerlas y esto ha sido objeto también
de debate efectivas desde la justicia
desde la democracia y desde la cohesión
social y territorial abogando por una
transformación que cree más inclusión y
no deje perdedores por el camino en
resumen para mi querido presidente pues
es un auténtico placer poder recibirte
aquí en el Palacio de la moncloa creo
que se abre una etapa muy importante
para reforzar los vínculos que nos unen
a ambos países también es cierto que
partimos de una base extraordinariamente
sólida a partir de la relación histórica
fructífera y larga entre ambos países y
ahora por tanto es el momento de
reforzar ese impulso En beneficio de
nuestras sociedades a las que Bueno pues
nos une no solo una lengua y una cultura
llena de referentes comunes sino un
futuro lleno de esperanza y también la
voluntad compartida de afrontar Unidos y
unidas en los grandes retos que tenemos
por delante y sin más presidente pues te
cedo la palabra
bien
en pocos días en el mes de julio
se reúne toda América Latina a través de
la celac
con toda la Unión Europea
un evento que precisamente no se hacía
desde el 2015 hoy en un contexto
político económico mundial muy diferente
Y eso implica lo hemos discutido así
charlado así que esa reunión no sea una
reunión más
sino que implica un hito
un Cambio de fase
en la relación económica y política
entre las dos regiones sus regiones como
queramos llamarla
atendiendo su historia común de alguna
manera
pero sobre todo las posibilidades
futuras
Aquí
más o menos lo que hemos dialogado es
que América Latina deje de ser el
recinto de la producción de materias
primas
muchas de carácter de carácter
extractivo
exportando a países que antaño tenían
plataformas de producción muy fuerte que
luego se deslocalizó en el mundo
fundamentalmente en Asia
sino que ahora podemos entrar a una fase
donde la plataforma productiva sea común
produzcamos aquí
produzcamos allá en América Latina al
final Esa es la base real de la riqueza
contemporánea
y compartamos entonces la gran
potencialidad suramericana
latinoamericana que es su potencial de
energías limpias quizás la mayor en todo
el planeta Tierra
aquí entonces la relación se convierte
en una sociedad
hacernos socios de un mundo más
productivo indudablemente
por tanto más próspero que es necesario
para
grandes secciones de la población
latinoamericana hoy con muchas carencias
y limpio
descarbonizado como llaman los
científicos ahora que es fundamental Ya
lo hemos dicho una y otra vez para que
la especie humana siga
existiendo en el planeta
por tanto esa reunión como un objetivo
que ya se acerca y hasta muy aquí ojalá
y ese es el trabajo conjunto de nuestros
países de nuestros gobiernos
sea el que se convierta un hito de
cambio
y no un evento más que al final ni se
recuerda
en los puntos que aquí se han acordado
de carácter bilateral
tenemos se han mencionado algunos por
el jefe de gobierno de España
Pedro Sánchez Pero hay uno del cual yo
cogí una influencia
porque coincidió con que estaba aquí
para esos días que es el tema laboral
hoy en reforma en Colombia
la condición del trabajador o de la
trabajadora
es el mejor síntoma de la riqueza de una
sociedad
y no se miden cuánto tiempo de trabajo
dura la jornada hacia su extensión sino
al contrario En cuánto tiempo libre
queda
decíamos en el discurso del primero de
mayo que la riqueza de las sociedades
empieza a ser y será cada vez más el
tiempo de trabajo libre el tiempo de
trabajo no el tiempo de vida libre que
el trabajo quita
eso implica sociedades más productivas
para que no disminuya la riqueza y otra
Concepción que no tiene que ver
ni con mundos de esclavistas ni feudales
de antaño
que a veces quisiéramos regresar algunos
sectores de la sociedad quisieran
regresar a ese tipo de sociedades ni
tampoco ese viejo capitalismo salvaje
que sustentaba la ganancia en la
extensión de la jornada y que poco tiene
que ver con la realidad del conocimiento
humano
contemporáneo con las posibilidades
actuales de la productividad
entonces siguiendo El ejemplo
queremos una reforma laboral aquí se ha
logrado a través de un decreto real creo
que ya ley no me acuerdo el proceso
de dignidad laboral aquí coincidimos los
dos gobiernos en el mismo objetivo
que el pueblo trabajador tenga jornadas
menos extensas más estables
la estabilidad es un concepto
fundamental en la seguridad
que no llamaré solamente jurídica sino
la seguridad de la vida que resulta ser
terriblemente más importante y de la que
poco se habla
la seguridad humana
tuvimos un acuerdo alrededor del
memorando de transporte
que se centra básicamente en Cómo ayudar
a Colombia a algo que perdimos
lamentablemente que es no solamente la
red de infraestructura ferroviaria sino
el conocimiento ferroviario que hoy es
fundamental dado que es una movilidad
impulsada por energía eléctrica que
puede ser limpia y segundo porque por
pasajero termina consumiendo menos
energía que cualquier otro modo de
transporte
aquí hay un acuerdo un memorando
alrededor de las energías limpias Si
queremos a España en tierra colombiana
generando energías limpias allí donde es
rentable en sociedad con los pueblos
ancestrales allí donde ellos están que
muestra un camino en el mundo sobre la
pertinencia de este tipo de energía el
viento el sol
Tenemos aquí firmado un acuerdo de
reconocimiento mutuo en materia de
acceso a la universidad eso palabras más
palabras más menos significa una mejor
más rápida
homólada homologación de títulos
tanto de la juventudes o en general de
la ciudadanía española en Colombia
como de la ciudadanía colombiana aquí
Creo que uno de los ejes quizás más
gratificantes de unos acuerdos alrededor
de la migración tiene que ver con la
educación
porque la población migrante al tener
conocimientos dona a la sociedad que
recibe
y aquí la palabra Don es clave dona una
riqueza que se produjo allá pero que se
puede invertir aquí y viceversa la
homologación es uno de los acuerdos aquí
firmados es paralelo ya se firmó ese
acuerdo antes en Bogotá
a la transparencia en el tiempo
pensional
firmamos un acuerdo que es de la oit que
también tiene que ver con el trabajo y
es que los tiempos
trabajados en el país que recibe a la
persona se conmute con el sistema
pensional del origen de la persona no se
pierda como si no hubiera existido el
trabajo sino que sea parte de esa
conmutación para el derecho a la pensión